what is going on everybody welcome to a
bit of a directional video since we
return about where are we gonna go
forward now so Python programming is
great but let's be honest we've pretty
much covered everything there is to know
about Python so what's the next language
that we should cover in this year
channel and you know some of the
trendier languages we've got like go has
come out and it's gaining a lot of
popularity but you know what go can just
go away because what we're gonna be
talking about is past Gow Pascal has got
to be one of the grooviest languages
that is still around today because let
me tell you this language came out and
was developed in the 1960s and really
came out and gained popularity ever
since the 1970s so this language is
pretty much where is where it's at you
know so here we go this is an example of
a tutorial website we'll probably try to
make one kind of like this one and first
of all when it ends in dot PHP you know
this is the good stuff so we'll come
down here and so here's like an example
program and stuff this your first few
steps don't worry we're not gonna make
this the first tutorial that's gonna
take at least 30 minutes this was just
an introduction to Pascal but anyway so
it's a lot like Python you've got line
by line basically it's a scripting
language and you need to find yourself
at the top and at the very bottom you've
got your main loop and that is just
denoted with your beginning and end here
so pretty cool stuff you do have to
define variables right at the top that's
something you might not be comfortable
with initially we do also have the use
of the the colons fairly often in the
semicolons at the end of lines is
required now but you'll you'll be you'll
just you'll get used to that it's no
problem also as a side note you guys
probably won't even notice but as time
has gone on since I post sample code
online and on github and I have
text-based tutorials I don't really see
the point of having 1080p because the
reason we had 1080p was so you can see
the text
as I was going but now I don't really
see the point of that plus it's taking a
long time to render videos in 1080p I
just don't want to do that also heats up
my room we're about to hit summertime in
Texas so I'm going to drop the clarity
just a little bit and you probably won't
even know to say it we'll probably do
like maybe 240 or something like that
and so hopefully that'll be okay I
probably shouldn't even brought it up
because y'all won't even notice but
anyway that's that if you have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below as always otherwise happy
April 1st